- You know, for a large
scale organizations, that--
- Really quick, I apologize.
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- It is "Interrupted By."
(upbeat music)
We have rebranded my podcast
to "Interrupted By Gary V."
So I apologize upfront if I interrupt.
It's only out of sheer excitement
and trying to be as efficient
with our time as possible.
I'm so exited you're on the show.
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are
and a little bit about your career.
And I'm obviously very curious to
how you thought about the book
and then obviously I'd
like to get your take
on current events and shoot
the shit here a little bit.
- [Stephen] Sure.
- Thanks for being on.
- Sure, I'm Steve Schwarzman,
I'm professionally co
founder and chairman and CEO
of a company called Blackstone.
Blackstone is the largest
company in the world
that does what's called
alternative investing.
That's a private equity where
we're one of the largest
in the world, I think we're the largest.
Real estate, globally,
we're the largest owner of
real estate globally.
Hedge funds,
we're the largest allocator
to hedge funds in the world.
Leverage credit, where we
extend loans and other types
of securities to people
who want to borrow money.
- [Gary] Not the largest
in the world in that,
'cause you'd rather go there--
- No, one of the top two.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Understood.
Little more work on that one.
Fair enough.
(laughter)
- [Stephen] We got more work to do.
We do other things.
Like invest in live
science and growth equity,
which are newer type companies.
And we grow very rapidly.
We got about 550 billion dollars of assets
which won't mean much to most listeners,
but it's a lot for sure.
And we're one of the
most profitable companies
in money management in the world.
We have what's called market value
which is what the stock market values as
at about 68 billion dollars.
And I started the company with $400,000.
So in the capitalist world--
- [Gary] And when did you start that?
- 1985.
- [Gary] Keep going.
- So that's a huge success.
- [Gary] Yes!
All worlds by the way would
view that as a success.
- Yeah that's what I do professionally.
- [Gary] Understood.
Personally.
- I also do a lot of
stuff with philanthropy,
which is a long word.
But basically I give money to
start really unusual things.
I started a program in China,
called the Schwarzman Scholars.
And what it is, it's like
the Road Scholarship.
Where we take students
who are extraordinary
who graduated from university
for graduate degree,
masters in global affairs.
We bring them to China
to Schwarzman College,
which is an Oxford
Cambridge type of college,
where the students live there,
they take their meals there,
they have classes there.
And 40% of the students
are from the United States.
20% are from China.
And 40% are from other countries.
So basically there are
41 countries right now
sending students.
- [Gray] When did you start that?
- I started that, came
up with the idea 2011.
Our first class graduated in 2017.
So we have roughly about 150 students now.
Our max capacity as
we're growing it is 200.
These kids are astonishing.
- [Gary] Clearly.
- Really astonishing.
We got sponsorship from
the president of China,
the president of United States,
it's a very unusual thing.
That takes some of my time.
But I've also started
some other things around
artificial intelligence.
Because I'm concerned
about the impact of A.I.
In terms of disruption in the work force.
- [Gray] It's foregone conclusion.
Just like machines for farming.
- Well that's also true.
- [Gary] Yes, thank you.
- So I'm looking at that situation.
By the same token, A.I. can do
some astonishingly positive things.
I ended doing a very large donation to MIT
to start a new college of computing,
which on the one hand pushed
the technology forward,
but on the other hand a
place where we can take
people from around the
world and figure out
how to introduce this
technology on the basis
where it does the
minimum damage to society
and people in terms of unemployment.
And I've done something
similar but a little different
at Oxford University.
There we started another
A.I. ethics thing.
I gave a big facility for the humanities
because Oxford interestingly,
that's where it started.
They're number one in the
world as MIT's and science.
Oxford never had their
humanities departments together.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- So this will be the first
time where we'll be building
a big performing arts center.
We're gonna use humanities to inform that.
Importantly in A.I. because
Oxford got the number one
philosophy department, ethics
departments in the world.
We're gonna use that capability to inform
how humans react to
artificial intelligence.
- [Gary] Couple things.
Linkedin, I know you
guys are live so please
fire in your questions.
I know that is very much the
audience for this interview.
Steph, take it all the way back.
Where were you born and
what kind of kid were you?
- [Stephen] I was born in Philadelphia.
And what kind of kid was I?
- Are you a Philly sports fan?
- I was then but they
lost all the time so.
I've transferred my
loyalty, I've moved to--
- [Gary] Where are your current loyalties?
- I moved to New York in 1969.
- [Gary] Fair enough.
Good year for the Jets and the Mets.
And the Knicks.
- Well nobody can beat for the Jets,
it just requires too much
loyalty for too many periods,
too many decades.
- I've not missed a snap of
a New York Jets football game
since 1982.
- Well then you're a masochist.
(laughter)
You know, it got too bad--
- [Gary] Or deeply loyal.
- When they built a new stadium,
I thought it was really neat to get a box
and go on a regular basis.
Well, it's quite defeating
and so I give the tickets away
for the most part.
By the end of the season--
- [Gary] Do you do Jets
and Giants, or just Jets?
- [Stephen] Both.
- [Gary] Understood.
- By the end of the season
nobody would take them.
- [Gary] I understand.
Not been the best decade.
- Now that's for free.
- [Gary] I understand.
- They won't take them.
- The market is supply
and demand, my friend.
(laughter)
- The only group that
will take them actually,
none of my people would take them.
But I give the tickets away to veterans
and disabled veterans,
and they take them and have a good time.
But I must tell you, you
have to be an optimist
if you're a Jets fan.
- Or you just love the process.
I think when I think of
your level of success
or just anybody else.
If one does not love the
process, they have no shot.
And I genuinely, I spent
so much time in control
that it's actually fun
to offset a little bit
and be super passionate
about something you
don't have control over.
Which is why I've decided I'm going to
buy the New York Jets.
Because I want control.
Back to my happiness.
- Well a friend of mine,
Woody Johnson owns the team.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- And I try and give him
some advice sometime,
but apparently I'm not
an effective sales man.
(laughter)
- So you grew up in Philly,
what kind of kid where you?
were you a good student,
were you an entrepreneur
kind of hustler kid,
what kind of guy were you?
- Well I had two lives.
The first was in the city until I was 14.
And then the second was in the suburbs.
So, in the city I was an athlete
and I was a good student,
not at the top of my class
but I tried really hard.
- Solid.
- And that's sort of
what you did at that age.
- Was that a big conversation
in the household?
Like, be great at school?
- [Stephen] Well it was just assumed.
- There was no conversation.
It was a dictatorship.
- It was a culture.
- [Gary] Understood.
- Of do well.
- And where were you in the lineage,
were you the oldest?
- I was the oldest.
- [Gary] So even more so.
- Yeah you have a little
bit of pressure on that.
But I always remember being outside
and competing at something.
I just loved sports.
I moved to the suburbs and
it wasn't as difficult.
I grew up in an an area
with broken bottles all over
the playgrounds and if you
played soccer against somebody,
something bad could happen to you.
- Do you feel thought those
first 14 years in that
kind of environment gave
you some real advantages
form of grit and kid
of E.Q. kind of sense?
- Absolutely.
If I hadn't been raised
in a place like that,
I wouldn't understand.
I wouldn't have understood evil,
I wouldn't have understood bad behavior.
That bad things could
happen to nice people.
One of my closest friend when I was young,
his father was assassinated
when we were about 10
in some motel, I don't know
what this guy was doing
but my friend had a box
completely filled with money.
I wasn't even given money
so I was in a neighborhood
that was somewhat, I guess
you can call it challenged.
So, that was, my mother--
- And were your parents born here,
or did they emigrate--
- [Stephen] Excuse me?
- Were your parents born here in the U.S.?
- Yeah.
- And before that, who was--
- [Stephen] My great grandfather
came over from Austria
on one side of the
family and the other side
was from Ukraine, 1880's.
- [Gary] Understood.
- So I moved to the suburbs,
things have changed.
Everybody was lovely.
You know, I became president of the school
and the top athlete.
- Life was good.
- Life was astonishingly good,
unsuspectingly good.
And has more or less remained so.
And if my mother hadn't
beaten my dad up to move
'cause he didn't want to move
and get us in a better school district.
She just did it for the school district.
Then I wouldn't be sitting here with you.
- What drew you to finance?
- Well that was an accident,
I didn't know anything about finance.
In fact I got hired when
I graduated from college.
I didn't even have a job.
- What did you think you were
gonna do in those college
years after school?
- I had actually, surprisingly no idea.
- Why?
Were you so focused on the
enjoyment of those four years,
did you have so many interests,
you were crippled by that,
did you have a main interest
that faded towards the end of it?
What was the variable there?
- I mean, I was interested in university.
In learning how to think,
excelling,
I wasn't a joiner of organizations.
My first English paper,
I got a 68% on "Bartleby, the
Scrivener" by Herman Melville.
My second English paper I got a 66%.
This was a trend even I could recognize
was not so good.
And if I continued would result in--
- [Gary] Demise.
- In my not being university.
So I fortunately had a teacher,
called me in for a meeting
and he said Mr. Schwarzman,
we're here to talk about
your English papers.
I said why would we do that?
(laughter)
I said there's really no reason for me.
And he said, I don't understand
why you would think that.
I said because I had nothing
to say and I said it poorly
in those papers.
And he said, my god you're not stupid!
He said you just can't
think and you can't write.
He said, so I can't teach
you both at the same time.
So I'll start off
teaching you how to write.
I'll give you the answers to the essays
and will teach you the answers to write,
'cause you can't think and
write at the same time.
He said, then after you learn how to write
I'll teach you how to think.
So I ended up on Dean's
list, I went to Yale
so it wasn't like a bad school.
I ended up on Dean's list which
is the top 10% of the class
by the end of the first year.
So, I was interested in
sort of learning things.
- [Gary] Steph, what do you
think of the current state of
how we package and process education?
- [Stephen] I think education
is not doing a good job.
- [Gary] No shit.
- For the people it's intended to help.
There's probably a lot
of reasons for that.
Whether it's primary or secondary.
University is different.
We have some great universities,
so that's not a broken system in the way
primary, secondary.
- At the level of scale that you play with
the companies that you get involved with,
at the P.E. level or the hedge fund level.
At that scale, I'm sure you
recognize connection point
between large organizations
in the business world
and large organizations in
the environment of education.
- [Stephen] Absolutely.
- It is stunning to me for
what I do for a living,
the complete inability for
the fortune 500 landscape
to have adjusted to the
communications infrastructure
that the internet at this
maturity level has created.
In your world, I do not believe the vast
majority of your world yet
has recognized the stunning
amount of money that big
brands waste everyday
on communication.
And I'm talking to the delta
on the 90 cents on the dollar.
I often say, once the
activist investors actually
understand, forget about printing
on both sides of the paper
or travel, or cutting overhead.
That the sheer money that the fortune 500
wastes everyday on marketing.
It's gonna get really interesting.
It's been the inability of
Madison Avenue, Wall Street,
and the corporate landscape
to adjust to the sheer
speed of consumer behavior.
There's a complete compt to
the same thing on education.
We continue to teach
kids to memorize stuff
when the information is
literally on their phone.
- Well, as to the corporate world.
You usually have a generational issue
where the people in
charge aren't the people
who've learned the
breakthrough technologies
that have happened over the last years.
- [Gary] That's correct.
Or Steph, the compensation
that that leadership has
doesn't, the infrastructure
of short term numbers
and being able to cash out
within two or three years
when you're out of the position
even though you've only been
there for two to three years.
Doesn't necessarily put
CEO's in today's landscape
in a position to actually
care about the health
of a business a decade from today.
- [Stephen] Well that
one I'll fight you on.
- Please.
- Because the person
you see in that position
has come up through a
variety of other positions.
And people who spend
their life doing something
aren't necessarily all
short term oriented.
- [Gary] No they're not.
- So they want their organization,
just like you want you
podcast to be a winner.
- Well let's play that a
little bit differently.
It's very different to be an executive
who spent within the McDonald's Inc
to then become the CMO but then transfer
and go work at 3G on Burger King,
is quite different than
me being in perpetuity
with my personal brand.
- Well I'm in perpetuity
with my personal brand
at Blackstone.
- [Gary] Sure, but we're
not talking about you.
- [Stephen] I understand.
- We're talking about
executives that run companies
who transact on stock price,
who also can spend 15 to
20 years to get to that
point where they're
really making economics.
By the way, you'll appreciate this.
I don't blame that, that's human behavior.
I don't think it's a negative.
But I think it's a really
interesting dynamic.
- [Stephen] That's a separate subject
than introduction and
effectiveness of technology
for large scale organization.
- Real quick, I apologize,
it is "Interrupted By."
- [Stephen] No problem.
- You'll appreciate this.
I think it's fascinating dynamic.
Yes.
But it's also the reason, some, not all,
this is always a some game right.
Struggle with taking
the one step backwards
to make the capital investments
to have the patience
around consumer behavior
in lieu of milking out
the infrastructure cost they invested in
within a half decade period.
- I think it's to the
extent that that's true,
but I don't think it's
an economic decision.
I think it's a lack of familiarity.
If people understood
how profoundly they can
penetrate the market or be effective,
they would do it.
- Steve--
- Because the other problem
is if you're not doing it,
somebody else is.
You're gonna be severely damaged.
So there is some rough frontier justice.
- It's a game of where is the balance.
Subconscious let alone the
conscious of the individual
that's leading on their balance
between legacy and currency.
- Well also, comfort.
In other words--
- [Gary] No that's very fair.
Because I think an
innovating entrepreneur,
she or he has on comfort in chaos
whereas a type A operator,
his only comfort is in
very different dynamic.
- Yeah.
Entrepreneurs don't
believe they're in chaos
you may think so but they don't.
The reason being an entrepreneur yourself
of a certain type or myself,
you only make decisions
when you feel you're right.
- 100%.
- You don't make decisions to take risk.
- [Gary] I couldn't agree with you more.
- The idea that entrepreneurs are risk
takers is complete bs.
- I'm a buyer, that's bullshit
for people that watch this show.
- They're risk takers
from the perspectives
of people who are watching them.
Not from them themselves.
- We think it's the reverse.
We think the person that's going this way
is actually going wrong.
- [Stephen] Right and so
people who are entrepreneurs
just see the same facts differently.
Or they actually obtain different facts.
And those different
facts show them something
that's wholly logical.
In my own case, I can
explain everything I do
exactly why I do it and
I'm also totally open
to someone proving that that's incorrect.
Because I don't want to be wrong.
But when I see it and if other people--
- [Gary] Don't.
- Sometimes you know what's interesting?
They see it but they don't want to change
what they're doing.
It's the nature of the
human being I found out.
- [Gary] Couldn't agree more.
- Because I'm not 25, so I
had a lot of observations
of the human condition.
Even with a wonderfully
conceived new thing,
if you describe it to people,
hardly anyone else would follow
because they're comfortable
doing whatever they're doing--
- [Gary] It goes back
to the point earlier,
the executives running these companies
in a lot of ways, in my opinion
I believe that the
discomfort and then look,
humans are game of vested
interest in the subconscious
and conscious, it's what it is.
It's an animalistic game.
- I don't quite understand it fully.
I'm grateful it exists because it's helped
my little corner of the world.
- I'm sorry to interrupt,
in this perspective of watching operators
give me a couple of your
favorite operators in the balance
of let's call, let's sum
up what we're talking about
right now, the balance of black and white,
versus the gray of
operations and strategy.
Who stood out?
Some of the investments you've made
where you watched from
afar that have really
as you've gotten closer and watched,
you've just gotten fond of
or unique or interesting?
- Well, I actually don't
encounter people in that way
and think about them.
When I was younger there
was a guy operating
within that now obsolete
world who was the head of
GE named Jack Welsh.
He looked at everything as
if it was completely new.
He listened to everyone intensely.
He had this unique ability,
still does, he's still alive
to interrogate somebody and
learn everything they knew
in the shortest period
of time I have ever seen.
And then he'd take that on
board and to that with a
succession of people and
then come to a conclusion
that an organization was doing
something right or wrong,
could do better, should
go in a different thing.
And what he would do was
challenge and push them
to do that.
And he would go wherever
those insights were.
This is a completely
courageous person with a
giant brain, endless energy,
and took that company into
the largest market value
because of just the extraordinarily
nature of the person.
- [Gary] Of course, no question.
- I met him before he
had his job at the top,
and I was asked by the head of
his company to teach him finance.
That took like two days and
a limited number of hours
and he could suck out of my
brain anything I have in there.
Even stuff I didn't know and off he went.
And occasionally you run into these
extraordinary human beings.
- Why'd you write the book?
- [Stephen] I wrote the book because,
starting about 7 to 10 years ago,
people instead of my going and
selling them products that we had,
I'd meet somebody at the top,
particularly there was an
incident in the Middle East
with the head of a very
large Sovereign Wealth Fund,
which is savings of their country.
He was new and I had an introduction,
I was the first person he
was gonna meet outside of
his world before he was appointed.
And instead of a five minute handshake,
he wanted to know how to
run his organization better
because he wasn't experienced.
So I ended up spending
two and a half hours
telling him how to do stuff.
So for me it's pretty
easy, it's what I do.
- [Gary] It's what you do, I get it.
- I certainly could do that.
That surprised everybody
because that's not
what's supposed to happen.
And then when I was
going around the world,
which I do meeting groups
of people who give us money.
All of the sudden, nobody wanted
to hear about our products.
And this particular guy,
the first guy was very funny
I tried to sell him something
in the middle of showing him
what he ought to be doing,
he said, please Mr. Schwarzman
don't waste my time.
(laughter)
He said, we'll buy your products anyhow.
Your time is too precious
for me, I want to--
- [Gary] To be on the sales
pitch, I totally understand.
So that became the seed of
there's something there?
- Yeah and what happened
was that started happening
everywhere I went.
And then I realized that I was
spending two and a half hours
every time I was seeing somebody.
And if I wrote it down, then I could--
- [Gary] You could save some time?
- Then I could just give them the book.
(laughter)
It would save me the time.
- So it's a time arbitrage?
- Right that's what it was.
- [Gary] I love that.
- So what happened is now I
end up here talking about that
so that's another hour of my life.
- [Gary] I totally get it.
- So I basically blew it.
- Can I ask you a funny question?
And I think this will help the audience.
How much competitive spirit do you have
for the book to do well?
- Oh, I am exceptionally--
- [Gary] I kind of figured.
- Competitive.
- You know, it's clearly
not an economic play.
The spirit back to process
or back to loving a game,
there's a big part of your juice.
I mean, for you to be
here, there's a big part of
your juices to make it successful.
- [Stephen] Yeah, if you're
gonna do something, anything,
doesn't matter what it is.
There's a limited number
of things that you could
do in life.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And if you're gonna do
one, you better crush it.
- [Gary] Yep, I agree.
(laughter)
- That's part of what I say in the book,
if you're gonna do something,
because you have limited time,
it should be great.
- I'm very curious about this,
in the last two to three years,
what technology, what app, maybe Alexa,
what modern technology
have you enjoyed using?
On a personal level?
- Well, I was technological illiterate
basically until four years ago.
I was using a flip phone.
- [Gary] Love you.
Do you still have that flip phone?
I'd love to flip it on eBay.
- I actually have a few of them
because they're so obsolete
that we had to buy the last batch of them.
- Were you in this category
of some of my friends
that I love to razz where
you were getting your
emails printed out for you?
Or was it not that extreme?
'Cause I have a couple of dear friends
who are like a little further
along in their careers
and I was in a meeting three years ago and
in walks an admin with a stack of papers
and I could see the first top one
and I said, brother there's
no way you're printing
your emails?
And he said, yeah.
And I said that's fucking amazing.
Were you in that category?
Because that would excite me.
- I actually have somebody
at our management community
meetings, who has that stack
brought into the meeting.
(laughter)
So, no.
I actually read my emails.
- But what about in flip phone land,
only in four years ago.
You didn't have it on your phone.
- Yeah, they would print those.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Yes!
Thank you for going there sir.
- It became sort of crazy
because as I'm traveling around,
there'd be people meeting me with
these large stacks of things.
So I realized that I was a loser.
So, that's when I converted
to the iPad, the iPhone.
- [Gary] And now?
- And now--
- [Gary] You're efficient.
- I can't believe I was so--
- Stubborn.
- [Stephen] Stupid.
And so now you're caught
in traffic little bit,
and I was just sitting here doing things--
- [Gary] Getting things done.
Efficiency.
- And now, it is fascinating.
The people who generate
statistics for the US Government
and other governments talk
about lack of productivity
in the world as one of the
major drivers for slow growth.
Anybody who is living today,
who has all of these devices,
you're actually working
16, 18 hours a day.
You're always on.
It's 6, 7 days a week.
And the productivity, I
guess what used to called
white collar workers, you're
wearing a sweatshirt top.
So it's not like that.
The productivity is astonishing.
- [Gary] The tools are in place my friend.
It's the craftsmen.
The tools are in place.
But some of these jokers
are watching YouTube videos
for three hours during that time.
- That's not for me.
- [Gary] Understood.
(laughter)
- No, it's amazing.
I just got the pictures,
I was waiting for you.
From one of my partners in Tokyo.
From New York in Tokyo
with a group of people.
Everybody's smiling,
it's like a group thing.
So I can feel exactly
what they're feeling.
- [Gary] Love that.
It's context.
- And it's instantaneous.
- [Gary] Yes, speeding context.
- It's so amazing.
- Do you want to give questions?
- [Male] You want a phone number, or just?
- Yeah, let's do the phone number,
I think somebody will have the thrill.
Go ahead.
- [Male] 205-896-6792.
- Name?
- What I would say before
we start with the question,
just in terms of competition, my nature.
- [Gary] I'm listening.
- That the book is a New
York Times Bestseller.
Is an Amazon Best Book of the Year.
- [Cameron] Cameron.
- [Gary] Cameron, can
you hold on for a second.
- Best Book of the Year of 2019.
- [Cameron] Sure.
- Top Ten NonFiction at Barnes and Noble.
So--
- [Gary] You're making some damage.
- I just wanted to complete that thought.
- [Gary] When we're done with this,
we'll look at our book scan numbers to see
what we compare to each other.
(laughter)
- I can interrupt too, you see.
- [Gary] That is the
punchline of this show sir.
(laughter)
Cameron, how are you?
You're on with Steph.
- [Cameron] Good, how are you Gary,
how are you Steve?
- I'm okay, thanks.
- [Cameron] I just want to
say, I'm from Philly too
I'm living in the outskirts
right in the suburbs as well.
- [Gary] Very nice.
- [Cameron] All right quick question,
just a little recap.
I used to be a professional ballet dancer
and I came back home to
take care of my sick mother.
Right now I'm in a position
where I'm being pressured
to go back to school to get
some sort of graduate degree.
- By whom?
Cam?
- [Cameron] By my mother.
- Keep going.
- [Cameron] So I'm kind
of in this weird, anyway,
I'm in that but I'm also I have
entrepreneurial tendencies.
I'm also represented and I'm
working as an actor as well.
So I'm in this dual, creative,
but what are you gonna
do with money?
But I have a side hustle so
I'm just trying to figure out
where are my next play is right now and
how to really communicate
with people in my family to
let them know it's gonna be okay?
- Steph?
- Well are you asking where to go?
What to do?
- [Gary] Yep.
- That's a tough one because
I don't know you that well.
- [Cameron] Yeah I know.
- We can change that.
You can go to Steph's
house today if you want.
I'm sure he'll be thrilled to have dinner.
(laughter)
Steph's a wild show.
- Might be able to do that.
(laughter)
- [Gary] Probably not.
- Probably not.
- On a general term, when
you hear something like that
Steph and obviously if you
have your own question,
what are some of the pneumatics?
That you've seen or had the recognition?
- If you, sounds like you
love the creative world.
And the performing arts
of one type or another.
So, this is actually funny,
I was sitting next to
a lady yesterday who's in
her mid 70's who was dancing
for the Royal Ballet when she was younger,
a pupil of ballet.
And you probably would do
well to stick with that love
because people tend to
do things they love.
But, you don't have to necessarily do it
just as a creative performer.
You can take that and look
at ways where you can use
your entrepreneurial
instincts to take some aspect
of the performing arts and
try and commercialize those
so that way you can basically
satisfy two of your needs.
Going to graduate school depends
what kind of graduate school.
Typically getting more
education is a winner
in the game of live.
- Unless you're disguising
'cause you don't want to do.
- Well that's a separate thing.
- It sure is.
- But, there's something
that you can come up with.
But you ought to keep it.
Not as a completely
discontinuous event where
all of the sudden you're
marketing marshmallows
or something, doesn't sound like a fit.
- May not be.
Cam I think your issue at
hand is if you have a sick
mother and she's
emotionally or theoretically
or ideologically interested
in you going to more school,
that's an awfully
difficult position to put
a human being into.
However, under every
circumstance, even this
ridiculously difficult one,
I am an absolute buyer of living your life
to make yourself happy
first and people around you
will have collateral effects of you
finding your own happiness.
Either when you find you
own happiness and success,
they've said, they've cheered all along
or much more importantly
to me and the hidden
game of this that I continue
to see among society,
I do not want people to
have resentment towards
their loved ones in a
decade or two because
they followed their path versus their own.
Whether you win or lose
by going your route,
in the end your relationship
with that loved one,
whether they're still here or not,
is always far greater
because you must avoid that
resentment at all costs.
- [Cameron] Exactly.
- When you layer Steph's
proper point that people
tend to excel in the things they love,
into two things that matter the most,
financial viability, for sure.
Commerce, commercial, yes
I'm a fan, I'm a capitalist.
Number two, happiness.
In this juxtaposition between
the balance of happiness
and finances, I'm always going with tie,
goes to the rather to finance.
Excuse me, happiness.
I want people to understand that.
This is actually, without
knowing you, very clear to me.
However, you've gotta live
with the consequences of it.
Not me.
But I couldn't implore you
more to execute against
your own happiness and hopefully
you can keep that conviction even when
the crowd in the sidelines
continue to cheer and or boo.
- [Cameron] Right.
Thank you Gary.
And one thing, you've
been such an inspiration.
I've actually started
recording for a podcast,
meet with people in the industry
and kind of taking your blueprint and--
- Please do.
- [Cameron] And my side
hustle is creative.
I do tie dye for friends and family
and anybody else who wants any.
And so--
- Cam, sorry to cut you off.
It is "Interrupted By Gary V." now.
- [Cameron] Yeah that's
right, I'm used to it.
- The key here is I
wanted to say something.
What I'm proud of you
for is I live in a world
and we now live in a world
with keyboard warriors
and technology communication
infrastructures
where people just talk.
People have always talked,
now you can visually see it.
People love to talk and not
back up that talk with action.
I'm proud of you for doing action.
The podcast and tie dye.
Continue to actually move
and make and create and do.
That is always a variable that unlocks
serendipity and opportunity.
- [Cameron] Yes.
- Thank you brother, take care.
Let's get another call in.
Steph, what have we not touched on?
We're gonna do another call,
we got a couple more minutes.
I know you're on a busy schedule.
Anything we didn't touch on?
Or things.
I thing I love about this
show is I've come to realize
I'm actually getting tested
to see if I'm dyslexic.
I cannot consume information,
I've come to realize,
in written form.
And so I don't tend to read a lot of books
but I'm quite audio and
I'm definitely visual.
And I know Jack quite well
and we're really friendly
and we have a lot of
similarities of extracting
information out of context
especially in person,
forget it.
Off the charts.
But what I've loved about
my audience is for me
I don't care about how
one learns or consumes.
They need to be self
aware on how they do that.
This is an audience that
reads quite a bit of books.
So we will convert some books out of this.
But is there anything that
one needs to learn about this
or anything we haven't touched on?
Sorry who is this?
Kevin?
- [Male] Tony.
- [Tony] Tony.
- Tony how are you?
It's Gary Vaynerchuk you're
one with Steph Schwarzman.
- [Tony] Hey Gary how are ya?
How you doing Steph?
- I'm hanging in there.
- [Tony] Thank you for taking my call.
I just have a question.
I've been a real estate
broker for 15 years now.
I've always had a passion
for real estate development
and we just kinda sell into it by god,
by serendipity.
We ended up assembling a
huge development inertia
half a million square feet.
And we got a financial
partner to partner with us
and we're going to these
uncharted territories
in other wise related real estate funds.
We're going into these
uncharted territories.
How do you kinda keep
that confidence and grit
within new territories
that we've never explored,
like I'm taking classes
at NYU for development.
Doing everything I can.
But how do you keep that confidence?
And that game fees when you're
dealing with these big guys?
- When you're doing something that's new,
if you're not confident,
that's an inhibition to going there.
So the way you get confident
is learning things.
There's nothing like
having somebody around
who actually knows what they're doing.
And so, what you should
do if you haven't already
is whether it's hire one or
two people who really know
and have been in that environment.
Have seen whatever you're doing.
Most things aren't new,
they're just new to you.
And that's normal.
- And to add on.
Even if they're new, the
nuances and pattern recognitions
could be deployed from the past.
Every theory I have on
this marketing waste
is because everybody wasted money on radio
when television became the platform.
It's the same thing that's happening now.
It's complete pattern recognition.
Continue Steph.
- Yeah, so.
You could maybe bring on
one or two people in either
permanent or part time
capacity as an advisor.
And of course--
- Or freelance.
Like, there's a lot of economic
trades that can be done.
You can back them
depending on the seniority
and things of that nature.
There's a lot more ways to
do it than people realize.
- But everything I do, I
do it from a position of
real comfort not of being worried.
And the reason is I've
learned something that gets
me to that point.
And to really push the
button and go forward
you have to have that sense.
- [Gary] You know Tony,
it's really funny listening to Steph.
I'm kind of equating a connection point.
For me, I'm so narrow,
I so stay in my lane.
It's really funny.
I never feel like I'm risking
either, I really don't.
I'm so in my lane.
I'm aware when I'm out of my lane.
And the times I've risked,
there's such small risks.
Anytime I risk, go
anywhere out of my lane,
I'm basically betting
something I can take to zero.
- [Tony] Thanks guys.
- Yeah, because you might go to zero.
- [Gary] Often you do.
But I'm paying for the
context and the learning.
And if I win then it's a
double muzzle but that's fine.
I've actually invested
for the context extract.
- [Tony] Yeah, I have
another partner who has
some experience but when
we're in these conversations,
I hear something new and
I look it up right away.
- Tony on that front,
honestly this is a human game.
If you went to the tippy top of Related,
who's my partner Steph Ross.
If you just make fun of the Dolphins
you're already three
fourths of the way there.
(laughter)
But Tony, I'm really going honest there.
I think people get
intimidated way too much.
This is just a human game.
Here's my punchline, 97%
of them just say no anyway.
And if you stay in your lane,
listen, my career has been
built on the fact that
the smartest people I've
come across reacted in
very polarizing responses
one way or the other.
That, oh my god, I found
this new uncharted guy,
he's brilliant.
Or, this guy's crazy,
he's completely wrong.
And then by being right historically,
the half that I lost
upfront, I won double with.
- [Tony] Yeah, that's true.
- So this is just about execution brother.
- [Tony] You're right.
- People are so insecure about
other people's judgements.
I prefer.
This is why I love the Jets so much Steph.
I prefer when people think I'm wrong
or underestimate me,
to actually when they
think that I'm right.
Because ultimately doesn't
care if Steph and I
think you're smart or dumb
or silly or unbelievable.
The net result is gonna be
the judge in the majoris
not somebody who's achieved
something in the past.
- [Tony] Yeah, thank god
because you're so right.
Because we did something
that nobody else is doing.
We went into Westchester
to do development.
I left the city doing broker,
the city is maxed out
at this point right now.
There's so much competition.
I see a shift of all the millennials,
when they're having kids,
they're gonna want to go the suburbs
but still have access to the city.
So we went a half hour
outside on the train line,
a walk from the train,
it's in their shell.
Where it was uncharted,
nothing was happening.
And we assembled the
Schultz project and now
all these big developers
are coming four years later.
And it's just a huge boom.
- That's great.
- [Tony] I saw my vision moving on
and we really like the Blue
Ocean Strategy back then.
But now all the sharks
are coming, it's amazing.
So you got some advice.
- You got it Tony, we
wish you a lot of success.
Good luck brother.
- [Tony] Thank you.
- Steph, let's wrap up here.
- Well.
I think one of the things I
was trying to teach people
is to do things they like 'cause
that's what they're good at.
Be prepared.
Have foundational skills
that get you from A to B.
Be very careful about
what you choose to do,
where you choose to deploy yourself
as a human resource.
Wait for something that is
really terrific to come by.
- Where do you sit on patience?
You think about that?
You don't?
It's in your lexicon?
It's not?
- As a person?
- [Gary] Yes.
- I'm interpersonally impatient
because I always want to
get to the next thing.
That's why when you have a
show based on interrupting
people, I do that all the time.
It's what I do.
(laughter)
When I've had enough.
I've learned what--
- You're trying to bring
value to them as well.
It's not a negative, it's a positive.
- But in your own life,
you should wait until
you see something that's
got enormous potential,
enormous running room.
Because you only can do one thing at once.
- [Gary] Meaningfully.
- With excellence.
If you deploy yourself on a little thing,
you may be excellent but
you sorta get no place.
- [Gary] That's right, where you cap out.
- And then something much
more interesting comes by
and you believe it's more
interesting but you can't get out
of what you're doing 'cause
you're already committed.
- A lot of people of success
don't recognize that jumping
off of something that is
successful already for
this other opportunity is
the right move.
But they're incapable to step backwards
or too forward.
- But you always have to be measuring.
The feel.
Whenever we go into something,
I always say, how wonderful can this be?
How big can this be?
Are all the resources there?
Money?
The idea that people--
- Steph, where have you made mistakes?
What's the pattern,
so for me the mistakes early in my career,
the first three companies
I invested in after
building a wine business for my family
were Facebook, Twitter, and Tumblr.
And well pre IPO so I'm
like, oh I'm a genius.
But then when I realized, oh,
in the early days I was
betting on Mark and David
and Jack and Ev as much as the idea.
When they've hit, I started
realizing I was unbelievably
consumer centric and I could
see things that would win.
One of my biggest losses,
an app called Yobongo,
ended up being Tinder three years later,
I was right about the thesis.
I was wrong about the executive.
I needed to learn that,
I would always put myself
in the jockey position,
I would know how to operate it.
So I needed to learn that.
That's where I made a lot of my mistakes.
The concept was right,
the operator was wrong.
Especially at that early of a stage,
when you go later it's a bit easier.
Did you have a common mistake
early on in your career?
- There's always a learning
curve when you're younger.
- [Gary] Yes always.
- When you're in your 20's,
you're in a lot of risk.
Because you don't know enough yet.
You're just as smart
as you'll ever will be.
But you don't have the context
to make those decisions.
- I apologize,
do you then believe that
that's a very good decade
to actually be in a
high risk, high reward,
happiness genre, to taste a lot of things
because that's a very
opportune time in theory
about accountabilities and relationships,
and many other variables?
Do you think that kids
at 22 to 30 are being
too conservative over
the last several decades
because they're supposed
to be in the real world,
versus actually taking
advantage of that decade
with the over lay of gathering context.
- It's high risk strategy
to take the approach
that you're talking about because if you
just stumble from mistake to mistake
and you're not particularly
gifted like yourself, where
you can't self correct,
that you end up with no
fundamental skills of any type.
And then you're like a
lost soul in your 30's.
- But you would agree
with me that many struggle
with the relationship with time
that being in your in your 30's is still
uncomfortably young.
- Yes but I was never
smarter than I was 32.
That's your max--
- Is that your number?
- Yes.
- Shit.
- That's when you think
you are the smartest person
in the world, when you're 32.
- [Gary] 'Cause fuck at 34 I think I am.
(laughter)
- Now the fact is, you're not.
But you've accumulated enough knowledge
and enough delusion and
you have such ginormous
crushing energy that--
- [Gary] D-Rock how old are you?
- [D-Rock] I'm old.
- [Gary] Understood.
Keep going Steph, sorry.
- So that's in effect when
you may be extremely potent.
But you also may be extremely dangerous.
- [Gary] Let me wrap
up here 'cause the team
is looking at me and
I'm sure you have to go
and I appreciate your extra time.
Couple random questions.
Are you on Tik Tok?
- No, but I know the guy
who launched Tik Tok.
- That makes all the sense in
the world for this interview.
- That's as close as I've got to Tik Tok.
- Have you got any context about it?
Do you know what's going in
the 10 to 18 year old demo
on that platform?
- No I just know there's
a limited time period
shots and you know the thing
is growing like crazy globally.
That's all I know about it.
- [Gary] Understood.
What's your favorite emoji?
- My favorite emoji is a heart.
- [Gary] That's a very good answer.
Parting shot.
Any last thought as we get out of here?
- No.
You know in terms of a parting shot,
life can be really fantastic.
But you have to have the
ability to always be focused
on something you can achieve.
That's in your comfort zone.
- [Gary] Are we talking
self awareness right now?
- Pushes you so it's life
of lifetime learning.
- How much do you think
humility is a key ingredient
to this level of success?
- I think humility comes with the volume
of things that you do because
no matter how good you are
as you ramp up the volume.
- [Gary] Take a lot of L's.
- You'll make mistakes.
And so all of us who have
external success have had
failures, misjudgments.
And you shake your head
and say what a dummy am I.
And it's the dummy
things, where you learn--
- [Gary] It's the fun stuff I agree.
Learning how not to beat
yourself up in those moments.
- Well, you actually can't
beat yourself up 'cause
they're so terrible that
you have to rescue yourself
from that stuff.
That's where you learn.
And driving to make things better.
Make yourself better.
Do things, almost like the ballet dancer.
What is a perfect pattedoie look like?
And imagining what those things could be
and then going and creating them
is what's lots of fun in life.
- Vayner Nation, buy Steph's
book because I want him
and his crew to know that a lot
of sales came from this show
and because I want the leverage of legacy.
And I really appreciate your time Steph
and continue to health and success.
- [Stephen] Oh thank you.
- Thank you.
- Great.
- Take care.
Bye everyone!